so I was born in Torquay on October 22nd
1990 roughly here now other people seem
to think that they had the best parents
in the world but they're wrong because I
do dad was an officer in the Royal Navy
and he worked at the Naval College in
Dartmouth which is where he lived mum
worked at the Ministry of Defence until
I was born without she took some years
off to look after me before she went
back to work and did a couple of jobs
now we didn't have a huge amount of
money as a family we didn't go on fancy
holidays or her fancy things but we were
happy I wouldn't have changed it for the
world when I was three we moved to a
village called [ __ ] down just outside of
bath here and dad started working away
from home now sometimes this is in
London so we would see him on the
weekends but sometimes he was on ship
which meant we wouldn't see him for
weeks or months at a time say if a lot
of my childhood it was just mum and me
and I was largely influenced by her
which is great because my mum is eight I
learned a lot of books and reading from
her I learned to love music the big
thing which mum didn't have spare time
is to sing and to sing opera so I went
to a lot of rehearsals a lot of
rehearsals and from that I guess I
learned to love performers not just
music but also drama and from that I got
into films from a really young age I
would write scripts and draw contact art
and act out scenes from films but more
on that later I guess the most important
thing which mum and dad both gave me was
to always be curious and to always ask
questions neither of my parents went to
university but they're both really
intelligent as long as I can remember I
was encouraged to learn to read science
books to watch TV programs like natural
world and horizon I remember going to
London and just doing the big museums
not the normal tourist stuff I bloody
loved dinosaurs so a primary school I
was always the keen one the one who
stuck up his hand to once the teachers
questions I was really good at most
things but not outstanding at anything
but maths
was by far my least favourite subject I
was much more interested in English and
history which I found way easier I did
get bullied affair between the Keane one
but I did have some good friends one of
them was this kid called Charlie
McDonnell he went on to make a channel
called Charlie circle I can he was
actually pretty big influence later in
my life but
I'm getting ahead of myself again my two
best friends were John and Mark we met
in playgroup at age three and we're
still really good friends now at age 24
we went swimming together with our
families but the most important thing we
did together was Cubs and later Scouts
we progress through the Scout system
together for about ten years we've hit
up lots of new friends on the way
notably two guys called Tom and Theo the
five of us formed a core group that did
everything scouts could offer us we do
gliding rock climbing power boating
hiking in Switzerland canyoneering we
had a pretty awesome scout group you
name it we did it the funny thing is
though that despite having great friends
and the best parents I don't belong my
time at primary school being lonely and
unhappy I read a bunch of my old school
reports recently which said that I was a
happy child but maybe that was just a
performance I'd already started or maybe
my memories being selected things
definitely started looking at when I
started going to my secondary school we
moved all of eight miles from Kuhn down
to a town called qingcheng partly to be
close to my elderly paternal
grandparents and partly to get into the
catchment area for wells where school my
parents and I'd looked on a whole bunch
of schools in the area and they decided
that they liked the hook of wells way
the best I was actually later tab with
my parents that they could have afforded
to send me to private school or
supported me through uni and they
basically gambled that I'd be clever so
they sent me to Wellesley which was a
state comprehensive study more seriously
there suited me right down to the ground
and I started being really good at
English and science in particular but
towards the top of the class and pretty
much everything except math I was still
really bad at that though just about in
the top set I also started getting
involved in some extracurricular drama
music started playing the alto saxophone
I threw the discus at county level the
disadvantage of going to Iowa was that I
knew no one there I was only one from my
primary school to go and I got to know
some of my cheetah group really well and
I became good friends with David and
Michael who I watch school with every
day they lived on my Road and it helped
her we were played and collected
warhammer for the emperor but my best
friend was and is John
we met in a situation straight out of a
Nicholas Sparks novel in year 8 we did a
house rugby tournament and this lanky
ginger kid got crunched in a tackle and
laid out on the touchline
play carried on and it was winter so
this kind began to freeze and he went
blue and purple I wasn't playing so I
went out to
my blazer and I help them up to the
school nurse that he could warm up
because of that we started sitting
together in German we bonded over
marking test scores and Roman numerals
then GCSE history and then we just kept
going I love him he's like the brother I
never had
but anyway getting distracted now idiot
n normally kids in my school went on two
weeks of work experience at local
companies but I didn't end up doing this
because as part of a team from my school
I won a national competition to design a
new invention to be used in space we
designed a tent which would be used on
the surface of the Moon with the
imaginative aims team space tent and
generated a breathable atmosphere for
the astronauts inside winning the
competition meant when you spent two
weeks in America tour in the Johnson and
Kennedy Space Center's which was
absolutely awesome not least because we
got to see the space shuttle land a GCSE
I got the top results in my school only
because I seem to do more subjects than
anyone else more than school would even
let me do I couldn't decide between GCSE
history and geography as was required by
the option blocks so I just decided to
do geography in my spare time
this meant that ended up doing 11 GCSEs
and I got nine a thousand two A's the
two ways being a double computing and
they plagued me to this day
it was in my GCSEs that I decided I
really liked physics I wanted to go on
to uni and study it I realised when
science split into biology chemistry and
physics that all the cool stuff was in
physics so that was what I liked so I
choose my a-levels accordingly I did
maths further maths physics and
geography now my maths teacher he was an
absolutely inspirational woman called
Miss skirm thought that further maths
was up step too far for me I'd scraped
an a star in GCSE maths which she also
didn't think I could do and so she
reluctantly let me take further math the
subject particularly the statistics and
the pure stuff really pushed me but six
one was when I really came into my own I
was like two head boy I captain the
school debate team won awards of public
speaking played mixter men's hockey went
on expeditions to the Alps into the
Pyrenees and somehow I also got into
Oxford I applied to Oxford Durham
Manchester Leeds and morick and all for
physics and I managed to get offers from
them all despite having my Manchester
interview sprung on me and not even
going to my door interview but Oxford
was the one that I really cared about a
big influence on me applying was going
on the unique summer school I stayed in
modelling college for a week and loved
every bit of it it was the first time
that I thought maybe I could get in so I
applied to Jesus College
and that was partly decided by looking
at the research the physics teachers tip
which incidentally is a dumb idea don't
choose a college like that and I
basically chose it because it felt like
home when I walked around that
incidentally is a much better way of
choosing I went up for I think three
days of interviews in Oxford three
interviews of Jesus and wanted some
Peters which was the randomly allocated
college that I was given when I arrived
they all been pretty well though my Matt
interviewed Jesus was wanted the
scariest things I've ever done as it
turns out though Jesus was very
oversubscribed for physics and I just
missed out on a place there fortunately
however some Peters were very happy to
take me finding out that I got in was
one of the happiest moments of my life
though also one of the most stunned in a
sense it was a huge relief even though
I'd always told myself that I probably
wasn't gonna get in I knew that I was
going to be really disappointed in
myself if I didn't I also didn't want to
let my teachers or my parents down as it
was I remember how happy moment Appler
that [ __ ] my hand and I knew for sure
for one of the only times that he was
really proud of me of course I still had
to meet my three a offer this was before
he stars were a thing and in the end I
got A's across the board as well as
passing an open University module on
planets I took and getting one the first
ever a stars in a trial for the extended
project which I did on manned missions
to Mars so I became the first member of
my family's go to university and the
first one my school to go to Oxford for
physics well we actually had a great
year for Oxbridge emissions and instead
of sending the normal one or two we sent
four people to Oxford in Cambridge I was
really good friends with them all and I
have no doubt that we all spurred each
other on to success particularly my
friend Chris who graduated from Merton
College Oxford with a disgustingly high
first and is to this day the smartest
person I've ever met
going to uni is one of those big changes
in life like every TV show and film
tells you that you step into adulthood
and you become who you are at uni and I
only really realized the significance of
what was gonna happen the night before I
left when I was lying in bed looking all
the bags packed on my floor and I
realized I wasn't gonna be sleeping in
my room anymore adjusting to Oxford life
was something sleazy and tough I was
made to feel so welcomed by everybody in
st. Peter's it really is the friendliest
College and instantly fell at home so
that was easy the hard part was dealing
with the work I'd always told myself
that was going to be at the bottom of
the pack of physicists that
wasn't good enough to be there and that
to counter at this I should work as hard
and as constantly as I could
I've worked 60 hour weeks and do nothing
but work and see my girlfriend who
studied three hours away in Cambridge on
the weekends nothing else it was only at
the end of my first year that I started
to play in university Wynne band and to
be honest I think that saved me it gave
me something else to do an opportunity
to not feel like crap about myself and a
chance to make music because the thing
about working all the time like I did is
that it doesn't work without something
else to anchor your life around
everything slows down and you end up
accomplishing less than if you'd
allocated half the time and then done
something else in your free time because
of this I didn't do so great in first
year admittedly a third of the year
failed but I take full responsibility
for my personal failure that summer I
stayed in Oxford and I revised and in my
resets I got just under at first and
doing that was really significant for me
I felt like I beat my personal demon
things started looking up from there in
my second year I became the manager of
my wind band and I took part in and on
the departmental public speaking
competition I also took the teaching
physics and schools option and I won the
department Award for that too I even got
a practical commendation for work in the
lab I got a good t1 in 2nd year and had
loads of enthusiasm for going in third
year I loved the range of modules from
particle physics to general activity and
in the end of year exams I've got just a
hair's breadth under a first and then it
all went wrong after I took my third
year exams in the space of a weekend my
childhood pet our beautiful cat Henry
died and my girlfriend of three years
left me I was absolutely devastated I
was faced with the summer of no work and
no girlfriend and basically my life from
the past three years had vanished and I
had to rebuild who I was because I'd
made the mistake of only doing two
things and I hadn't diversified my
interests that summer I was very lucky
to get an internship at the abstract
physics department in Oxford which I
took to work out if a PhD was for me as
a student on a four-year course I only
start to think about my career after my
third year the internship was fantastic
for that it was a good routine to get
into it was a chance to learn new things
and some time by myself it was also
important because I became okay with who
I was and obviously did that and I got
some good work
but while I was okay with
summer when term started again in
October things got worse well I did
start to socialize more in college and
even took a few classes on meditation
and yoga I still worked far too hard I
didn't give myself enough personal time
as the year went on I became really
seriously unhappy I don't think people
realized at the time because I'm very
good at putting a brave face on things
and not being honest with my emotions
but I also wasn't honest with myself
about my situation I suppose I didn't
want to admit that I was struggling
because to do say would have been to
admit a weakness I was still functioning
though and just about got my problem
sheets in though I seriously struggled
to see my day in the life video for
example and I applied for some phd's I
was offered places at Oxford and reading
and I was over the moon to accept my
place at Oxford with a three year
scholarship or real dependent on me
getting a 2:1 or above at my degree I
was riding on a good t1 and I felt
confident no matter what happened I
should still get one overall however my
depression was starting to get out of
control in the run-up to my exams I
found myself locking myself in cupboards
in the library and just crying sometimes
for over an hour I just didn't know what
to do I couldn't understand what was
happening to me it all culminated when a
few days before my exams I had a
full-blown panic attack at first I
thought it was a heart attack but upon
googling symptoms of panic attack I
realized what was going on it seriously
shoot me up I genuinely felt like
knowledge had tumbled out of my head and
it made me feel like crap the logical
thing to do here of course would have
been to tell someone and asked to defer
my exams maybe it was obvious that I was
in no fit state to do them but I didn't
I hinted to a few friends that I was
struggling and I just carried on I was
just too proud to ask for help the days
before I finished my exams were the
darkest of my life I barely slept I
worked all day on things I didn't
understand and I started to hate myself
so much that I would cut myself it was
horrible but I did it and I not sure why
of course I did terribly in my exams but
passed them both which meant that I
still got a degree now the requirement
to get a 2:1 is to achieve 59.5% average
overall what I got was fifty nine point
four five percent my PhD supervisor told
me that she didn't care and
she would take musical Department to get
me my scholarship anyway but they flatly
refused and they pulled my funding I
later found out that she was absolutely
furious about this and made a formal
complaint to the University by the
biggest stroke of luck possible though
while this was all happening she was at
a conference and she mentioned to a
colleague the situation this colleague
had a career integration grant from the
EU and could take on PhD students while
he was in the math department at Exeter
we exchanged emails a college okayed it
and I got my Blaise here from this point
everything started looking up I moved
down to Exeter and I threw myself into
student life I took courses on advanced
maths and I started doing some original
if for now guided research I started
lifting weights seriously and I got
myself in shape I joined the a capella
Society because I thought that one of
the musical directors was fit and knew
lots about gaming and we've been going
out ever since I've been busy around the
clock with so many different things and
I'm incredibly lucky to have the friends
I have I moved into a house with three
guys from the department and I get to
sing almost every day with some of the
best people I know including my
girlfriend but there's a big element of
this story missing what about YouTube I
hear you cry when I applied to Oxford I
try to find out information about
student life by all possible means and
one of the things I did was of course to
search on YouTube but I turned up
nothing at that time only the side
business school had a channel instead
the most useful thing I found was
talking very briefly and buyer emailed
someone who did physics VAR a mutual
friend the personal honest depiction of
student life really reassured me and I
meant I had no qualms at all about
accepting my offer after spending a few
months at Oxford I realized that I had a
really valuable perspective not just as
somebody on the course but also having
talked to the Masons choosers so I made
a video I use my terrible 4 megapixel
camera and I edited it on that machine
at the university computing department
because I didn't own any editing
software I uploaded it to my channel and
I watched as its fuse crapped up one by
one when I hit a hundred views I was so
happy I thought I'd really hit it big so
I decided to make more videos seeing
that people were benefiting from the
first one and I went for my interview
questions and I did a Q&A and an FAQ in
the video and studying and people
somehow kept watching eventually I went
to some Peters and said that they should
make a YouTube channel because what I
was doing was working and they said ok
you make it
I did originally it was only gonna be
interviews with a few people that on a
student perspective I talked about but
it seemed grew into something much
bigger it went live in 2011 and it
changed how many colleges dealer access
work building on its success and trying
to find something to do with myself my
fourth year I hit on the idea of making
weekly vlogs to give an honest student
perspective on Oxford life and the Oxbow
project was born it started slowly but
especially after I was joined by Jamie
aka Jamie Mills it grew in size and by
the year's end it amassed hundreds and
thousands of fans
I pushed the university to continue the
project the next year is a collaboration
between undergraduates from across the
university but there wasn't much
interest so I created a channel myself
and I recruited five amazing students he
went on to get over a hundred thousand
views and a devoted following this year
we have six students who will take the
project even further and I'm confident
they're going to blaze a trail at
universities across the world will
follow so now I'm at an interesting
crossroads I've always imagined that I
would finish my PhD I do a postdoc and I
continue down that path as an academic
but not on so much media production
hundreds of videos all told as well as
radio and journalism I find myself drawn
down another path the idea of producing
scientific video content whether in an
online format like scishow or crash
course or on TV is a very appealing one
after my doctorate I will need to make a
choice to go in on one path or the other
and right now I honestly don't know
which I'll choose maybe I'll go down a
third path I've been increasingly
thinking about maybe directing a short
film these days I'm at a really exciting
position in my life where I have an
awful lot of opportunities presented to
me and I'm incredibly grateful for this
amazing online community which has
sprung up around the videos which I've
done and I know no matter what I choose
to do the future will support and be
there for me